why did I ever do to you enough honor no
why why do you shut me out what why do
you shut the world out what are you so
afraid I said sorry you something is
going on here
buddy we found it the lost city of nut
latest it's an Arabian horse Arabic it's
you're from New York ok how much as an
Arabic course its Arabian horse did how
much is no ray being horse no less than
15 grand 15 the hell of a wedding
present that redhead a bridesmaid
Melissa the redhead dude the warmth
rekkles on the nodes q1 from the
Coldplay concert that's Melissa well is
she coming she's a bridesmaid yeah is
she coming oh no not a cop I'm about to
make a citizen's arrest I make a
citizen's arrest too for what
impersonating an officer what you say
you are calm that's illegal is it this
is Lama do time for you gotta get all
your brother danger may look like yeah I
want to catch you then you wanna see my
weapon I want to see yours these clients
is this friend that's my nephew hey
catch all the boys
you